vendredi 26 octobre la fête de l'ail ou
pour les musulmans de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines s'annonce un
peu particulière en effet l'abattoir
mobile qui permettait aux familles de
procédé au rituel du sacrifice d'un
mouton ne fonctionnera pas le dispositif
était installé sur un terrain
d'elancourt le matériel appartient à la
ville mais cette année son maire et
ancien parlementaire jean-michel
fourgous ne veut plus assumer les coûts
de son exploitation il renvoie la
question au nouveau député socialiste et
c'est le député qui coordonne plusieurs
communes qui donne l'impulsion qui
trouve les moyens financiers et qui se
coordonnent avec l'état bien sûr pour
réussir une telle opération c'est une
très grosse opération le député n'a pas
de compétences juridiques et techniques
pour pour intervenir une fois de plus je
trouve vraiment irresponsable de la part
du maire de du maire d'elancourt qui a
été battue d'ailleurs aux législatives
d'entretenir à dessein cette confusion
c'est vraiment le maire d'elancourt la
ville elancourt qui propriétaire de
l'abattoir c'est elle qui a maîtrise le
foncier ainsi que les procédures qui
jusqu'à présent ont été mises en place
pour l'organisation cette fête
religieuse à cet abattoir n'a de réalité
des deux sens juridique que par la
délégation
des règles d'hygiène que l'état donne ou
mer et ça concerne les mères et les
collectivités locales j'ai été député
pendant excusez moi de dire ça j'ai été
député pendant 14 ans ma mission de
député la mission des députés
connais un peu hein voilà c'est de faire
les lois et nous contrôler l'action du
gouvernement fin juillet la communauté
d'agglomération avait proposé comme
alternative aux musulmans un marché au
vif proposition rejetée par le collectif
de saint quentin car jugées non
conformes aux rituels le maire de la
verrière encourage lui les musulmans à
s'organiser eux-mêmes je défends et je
continue à défendre la position
d'avoir une solution pérenne qui
permettent
la prise en charge par les associations
musulmans de se pratiquer et donc on
aide à trouver une solution duras quand
le plus vite possible dès l'année
prochaine ça c'est faux que vraiment
tout le monde se met au travail ou
honnêtement il ya suffisamment de
terrain il suffit de se poser un tout
petit peu je suis sûr quand on me ravi
de la bonne volonté jointe par téléphone
l'association des musulmans de trappes
dit craindre une pagaille la plus totale
et parle même d'un retour de dix ans en
arrière les abattoirs les plus proches à
savoir dreux et creil leur ont proposé
une centaine de moutons un nombre
insuffisant sachant que l'an dernier
mille trois cents bêtes avaient été
sacrifiés à elancourt en l'absence
d'abattoir temporaire sur le département
la direction départementale de la
protection des personnes redoutent que
les familles musulmanes et massivement
recours à l'abattage clandestin interdit
pour des raisons de sécurité sanitaire